welcome back to new rockstars this is
the big question the show that gives you
too much information about fictional sex
lives
since we have none of our own also our
video thumbnails could
become the cringe memes of twitter
accounts run by people also not
no one everyone sucks let's just chill
the [ __ ] out
hey i'm eric boss with me today is
philip molina
welcome back buddy it has been way too
long wow
is this how every episode starts now
some variant of it for sure
it it's we've gone into a darkest
timeline a lot of profanity
a lot of like uh uh preventative uh
triggered reactions to social media
blowback
so we're in a bunker congrats though on
everything hey
congrats to you we've accomplished some
big stuff since you've been away
of making this kind of stuff for us i
got to get you more shirts
no i only want to wear this one for the
rest of my life i made this shirt too
actually
look at that one that looks so cool uh
for those wondering
these are shirts that you can go buy
right now in new rockstar's official
merch store newrockstarsmerch.com this
is our this is the way mandalorian theme
shirt it's a custom
shirt limited edition we are running out
so quickly of these you gotta jump on
this fast and
when you get them for a few bucks more
you can write in a custom
shout out that will feature in our
wikileaks episode and the bottom ticker
it's just a really exciting thing that's
been a
fun way for us to connect with you guys
arnold uh i saw your shout out if you
want to fight you know where i am come
find me bro
you want to [ __ ] with me you're a quiet
boy compared to me
a quiet boy yeah we do allow threats we
don't allow
promoting your twitch channel all right
let's
dive into our big question this week
what are we talking about
is there any kind of question that could
bring me back
more than just uh we've been here before
we'll go there again but eric loss to
yoda
i believe the question on my end is does
the yoda species reproduce but
you're right the question really is
do yoda smash do you want to get wet
what
how do you need to hear it oh phillip
you are answer the question
in 30 seconds or less no this is a
longer question
it's a bigger question some might say
girthier question
phillip you reminded me of way back one
of our first episodes of big question
after the rise of skywalker we asked do
palpatine
yeah luckily we have an answer for this
question too
though it's less about a history of
romantic partners
and more pure ap biology boring you've
made it boring
no no it's gonna be fun also a year ago
one of our first ever episodes a big
question marina
and i talked about the question of how
baby yoda ages but we miss the question
that people really want to know is how
does it reproduce
he is a 50 year old baby and this is
important to
his reproductive process trust me you're
a 33 year old baby yeah
and i we still don't know if i'm capable
of reproducing
after the accident ever since the
radioactive spilling
but it came out of me not on me
oh yeah and in that episode we're able
to conclude that since the original yoda
claimed to have been a jedi master by
age 100
and he died at age 900 that the yoda
species must undergo some crazy rapid
period of maturation between
ages 50 and 100 there's just like no
18018 ton of aging ton of 18 and then a
grandpa for 100
800 years his growth just keeps spurting
once you wait
that long and you get bottled up like
that that's gonna happen
but okay everything changed very
recently philip uh we've been watching
the mandalorian season two
and in the first episode of that season
we got the seemingly throwaway line from
amy sedaris's character
pelimoto you know if this thing ever
divides or buds
i will gladly pay for the offspring i
made the same offer to your parents when
we were looking for new hosts
and they paid it or you paid it the buds
are all failed
as long as someone got paid i want to
know a dowry ended up in some pocket
somewhere
now when this line came out it felt like
a very subtle hint that the mystery of
baby otis biology and origin
is going to be coming up but uh put more
frankly how does the species reproduce
even more frankly as philip said did
yoda at some point
smash whatever word you would have used
and yoda speak
miso horny how's charger
he was completely charger lisa horny
annie
you've been away from new rock stars for
too long why did the part of my brain
just want to bring up yo to speak
immediately go to
jar jar banks because he's awesome
because uh one swamp creature is the
same as another
no no they're not all the same okay all
right um here's what we know about the
yoda species george lucas introduced
yoda of course in the empire strikes
back
as a mysterious mentor figure whose
background and species
name we would never know so he's a
mystery character he's a magical
character
he has no background he comes and he
goes
uh he's the subversive secret mysterious
stranger that enters the film and then
exits at the end oh remember those two
uh hayden christensen and george lucas
what a fun pairing
i gotta say that description sounds like
someone who
comes and goes he's a secret stranger
impregnating women across the galaxy
that sounds like a dad who goes out for
cigarettes and never comes back
for sure a cool day cool dad my dad was
more of a mysterious stranger
and the teacher's like go on why is he
in class
because i imagine this i skipped a step
i imagine this is take your dad to
school day and then this kid doesn't
have it today
that's the day you didn't take your dad
to school
my dad came to school because i had so
many bullies that's what you say if you
kick your dad's ass
my dad can't kick your dad's ass but i
kicked my dad to take my dad at school
it's like the day you had to fight your
dad to become a man take your dad to
school
but one of the more interesting early
explanations of what yoda is came in a
1997 book star wars the annotated
screenplays by laurent
bruzero lucas said quote
i wanted yoda to be the traditional kind
of character you find in fairy tales and
character is usually a frog or a wizened
old man on the side of the road
a hero is going down the road and meets
this poor and insignificant person
the goal or lesson is for the hero to
learn to respect
everybody and to pay attention to the
poorest person because that's where the
key to
his success will be kids you hear that
befriend the drifters
the creepy old man on the side don't
fear the drifter
come on baby you'll take go trust him
he'll take you to a wonderful world of
wizarding and magic
well ever since that came out there have
been three known members of the yoda
species
yoda the child in the mandalorian but
also yaddle
now yaddle is a female member of the
species seen on the jedi council and
phantom menace
did not return an attack of the clones
it was speculated that
she might have died during order 66
along with most of the jedi
but she did come up in a darth vader
comic as a kind of ghostly
specter that vader had to like fight off
in a vision and she was mentioned in
jedi fallen order as
maybe possibly surviving order 66
but we don't know but the importance of
yaddle at the very least tells us that
there are two known
sexes of the yoda species a male and
a female baby yoda was confirmed to be a
male of the species but the fact that
there are two sexes
why in biodiversity do we have two sexes
if not
for sex i gotta challenge some of this
do we do this where
i try to break you down yeah that's the
point of this
now i know that it's canon that yaddle
is female but do we really know that
like couldn't
she just be like a slightly younger than
yoda male with like
joe dirt hair or jesus hair seattle
could could just be a redneck or a jesus
figure and like remember this is
this came back what 1999 since the 90s
they didn't have nuanced portrayals of
gender if they wanted
everyone to be like yaddles a woman then
they they would have done the same thing
that they did with the
uh the sexy ass gremlin from gremlins oh
yeah
the lipstick and the flowing green hair
and the
leopard print booby hole that is a woman
i think uh yaddle is confirmed to be
female as far as visual dictionaries
confirm her to be
how visual yeah the official dictionary
these were books that i collected as a
young middle schooler i had the visual
dictionary for phantom minutes for
episode two for episode three
they had a visual dictionary for the
original trilogy
they confirmed gender using the visual
dictionary that's how
so much has been confirmed i know what
you're going for right now
official dictionaries are not sexy they
are the least sexy book in the world
this is why you can't reproduce you
learned it all from a star wars visual
dictionary it's like all right i put
that in my port and it goes woo
see what philip jokes about is really uh
half of new rockstars videos these days
are based on visual
dictionaries because there's no news
that's a song
this is the adult visual dictionary no
these are not brittles these are for
children
yes so george lucas in his 97 quote
mentioned a frog but there are other
amphibious races based on frogs there
was the frog lady in the second most
recent episode of the mandalorian
gungans are also of course frog based
frog based or jamaican
base that's not that's not me saying
that when the movie came out
do you do you remember that you were two
years old but there was this huge
backlash
like he based that off jamaicans uh poor
ahmed best
that guy was unfairly maligned
absolutely but
yeah there was some um some discomfort
with the
voice that he i don't think gives that
but fine we'll we'll go with frog
it is interesting in a recent video we
did go into the
whole idea of there may be a connection
with the fact that this frog lady and
baby yoda loves her eggs and maybe
there's some kind of like biological
connection go watch that video but
the yoda species is confirmed not to be
amphibious and
reptilian in nature there is one
specific detail
that makes it very clear what type of
genus and species well maybe not genius
and species but what type of class or
order
the uh the yoda species is any guesses
what it is philip
s musk sense musk
not musk not sin five females
thanks our sponsors musk well it is
connected it is the right organ of the
body
hair the yoda species grows hair it
seems like a small detail but it is a
very big deal
remember uh yoda has that thin silver
hair that he beautifully strokes back
and attacking the clones
yaddle has that thick brown joe dirt
braid
and then yeah baby yoda has some buzz
grown on top preteen yoda has some
frozen
going down below yeah the thing is
reptiles do not grow
fur or hair fur is insulation it's meant
to keep the animal warm
reptiles amphibians are cold-blooded
meaning their body temperatures
vary with that of their environments
birds have their feathers
and mammals with their fur are
considered warm blooded
meaning they maintain a constant body
temperature
so the hair tells us that the yoda
species including baby yoda
are mammals ooh interesting
and if you remember your ap bio there
are three types of mammals there are
the mono trees hot knot
and becky becky
oh we gotta tear that page out of the
slam bunk because if it gets back to
becky's parents they're gonna they're
part of the booster club they're gonna
sue the school yeah the three types of
mammals
monotremes those are the egg laying
mammals you know
duckbill platypus echidnas uh and then
there are marsupials
those are the ones with pouches right
kangaroos koalas uh you know a lot of
the ones in
australia and then uh placentals or
those are the ones that have
wounds placental sex human beings apes
uh bears elephants all the all the rest
but all three of these types
reproduce sexually none of them are
asexually reproducing
yeah there goes the dynamite there here
it goes question answer
with all of these there's some kind of
process by which it's two different sex
cells
heart fertilizing and then it and then
and this poops out homer homer why are
you showing us
uh philip that brings us to three
possible explanations for baby yoda's
birth the first is the old-fashioned way
bumping yoats
baby yoda could have been conceived
naturally via two
parent yodas and then gestated in a
placental sac or a pouch or
an egg like tommy like tommy did now
there is a weird thing with baby yoda
and
eggs as we have talked about also has a
weird thing with eggs i can't touch them
not allowed to legally there was that
whole thing in
chapter 10 where he was obsessed with
these eggs again go check out that other
video
but it wasn't just hunger it wasn't just
eating them he had this
natural almost you could say spiritual
connection with these things some
crazy familiarity also in season one we
talked about how
his carrier looks like an egg and i
think
both of those could be hints to him
being egg based to him
being a monotreme something like a
platypus or an echidna
those are the freakiest mammals that we
know about and baby yoda i think would
fit in that category
with his weird claws and his green skin
now this does not mean that baby yoda's
parents were definitely
yoda and or yaddle now many do point out
that yaddle did disappear after the
phantom menace but
baby yoda is 50 years old placing his
birth nine years before
phantom menace he's the same age as
anakin keep that in mind
as a well-known jedi master at the jedi
temple others would know if yaddle had a
kid
on the side not if it was like that
thing though where like you have a baby
a prom
and then you just do it in the bathroom
and then you go back to dancing and
nobody knows wait you give
birth at prague you don't remember this
no i'm from north florida not south
florida yeah in north florida you take
your dad to school
south florida you have a you become a
data problem
that's in the florida constitution i'm
pretty sure we voted on it all right but
that brings us to our second explanation
one that we have talked about in other
videos before that baby yoda could be
the result of
cloning of genetic uh experiments there
have been
clues we talked about before he drives
an el camino
um like baby yoda could be a clone of
yoda
himself you are the fire or
just a clone of another member of the
yoda species there's a guy dr pershing
who analyzed him in chapter three
he had a kamino patch and then now boba
fett's back on the show
he himself is a clone from kamino and we
learned in the rise of skywalker that uh
cloning was apparently an ongoing effort
by the sith
after the fall of the empire with
palpatine resurrecting in that film
as a clone body and nobody
disliked that yeah yeah that's that's
what people want to see more of
right cloning including so if cloning is
the explanation
philip i find it real weird that favreau
and filoni went to the effort of
including that one line from queel in
chapter seven
i've worked in the gene farms this one
looks
evolved too ugly that is such a dig
you know i know you ain't a clone you're
so ugly
why would we make two no one would have
drawn a blueprint of
this face you think we want more of this
this undercooked little
kremlin and i think just a little psa
from your uncle phillip and your uncle
eric you have to apply a bit of common
sense to movies and tv theories i know
we here at new rock stars love to go
conspiracy mode
but unless a character has a spelled out
reason to lie
they're probably telling the truth when
they say something when they say the
exact opposite of your theory
that thing is not a clue proving the
opposite of what they just said
you can't just say like oh they
mentioned anything at all so the exact
inverse of it must be true
i'm not a great fool so i can clearly
not choose the wine in front of you
but you must have known i was not a
great fool you would have counted on it
so i can clearly not choose the wine in
front of me truly you have a dizzying
intellect
don't go into these things with
confirmation bias if a character says
something and they die right after i
don't think he had a reason to cover up
a conspiracy
yeah we didn't kill gabe well that
conspiracy
is nope okay i'm sorry philip's drone
just lowered into the
uh joni all right we have arrived at our
third explanation which
is the craziest but might be the most
accurate
so he came from the force
ah oh of course this nonsense i don't
need your
religious [ __ ] so the one thing we
know about baby yoda the child
is that he is 50 years old he was born
in the year 41 bby
making him exactly the same age of
anakin skywalker
born the same year now anakin skywalker
was also born under mysterious
circumstances remember schmie told
qui-gon that there was no father
i carried him i gave birth i raised him
oh
um we all just believe
[Music]
now it is believed uh that palpatine
actually used the dark side magic to
conceive anakin via midichlorians in
shmee's womb
he's my middle name [ __ ] and there was
that line palpatine mentioned about
darth plagueis the wise
figuring out a way to create life he
could use the force
to influence the midichlorians
to create life
did you ever hear the tragedy about
darth plagueis the wise
no can we just not do this right now i
can
i just want to watch this opera it's not
that big a deal he got corona
oh that's it that's a change that's it
that's tragic that's sad that's sad
now i just think the precision of the
birth year
is super interesting that to me is seems
like the most deliberate aspect that
they've
written about this character so far
there is a deal that you might not love
but it is true we just learned about a
month ago from a new book
something important about baby yoda when
it comes to the concept of dyads do you
remember dyad's philip from motheriza
skywalker
i do they are a whole concept that a lot
of people get [ __ ] on because they're
like this came out of nowhere but i will
throw out there really quick
that the sith always had this weird rule
of two always
two there are no more
no less and you know that could have a
foundation in this diad concept
absolutely
so this new book comes directly from
pablo hidalgo he's the head of lucasfilm
story group he's really
the authority at this point of what is
and is not canon in star wars
there is a section in this book that
talks about dyads just
to remind everyone it's the dual
force-linked figures that ray and kylo
ren were revealed to be
that's why they're able to uh have those
force-time chats let's make the gym
great again do you have something a cow
or something you can put on
and there was a line that talked about
the unique ability of dyads to force
heal
to quote this book it says those in a
dyad possess
another unusual ability they can use
the force to heal a wounded person or
creature
but this act also requires that the
healer transfer some of their force
energy which can temporarily weaken them
etc etc etc so yeah the first instance
of force healing that we saw
on screen in star wars happened in the
mandalorian episode seven
with baby yoda and that came out the
same week of the rise of skywalker
and philip by this logic i think we have
a reason to believe that baby yoda might
be part of a dyad
boom you heard it here first baby yoda
got a girlfriend and
i think that girlfriend could be anakin
skywalker
oh annie you're born the same year lisa
horny
yeah and as you said phillip the whole
idea of the dyad does seem to come from
this idea the rule of two
and really that comes from george
lucas's vision of the star wars uh
nonology as a one of balanced poetry he
might say
they run there's always parallel forces
that are working in tanzania
jump and hump prime boom poetry are you
looking for this
i think we might be able to speculate
that when palpatine used dark magic to
spawn anakin skywalker the balance of
the universe could have somewhere else
sparked another supernatural conception
of an equal opposite to anakin
and then 50 years later here he is the
child baby yoda gathering all the
information
in summation the fact that the yoda
species is so rare
i think that would suggest that they
probably do
not because if they did you would just
see
more of them around that's how all
all species work maybe they only once
and it's
just so good or like they turn inside
out and die it's just like so good
but this no this sucks i hate this i'm
mad it's it's possible that
if it's the force the fact that shmee
might not have
to create anakin whatever baby yoda's
parent was
might not have reproduced sexually might
have been asexual
no get off stage this is the peachy
version that
disney would want to tell kids right no
it's just delivered by an egg somewhere
a hole goes in your body and there's
blood everywhere coming out of your head
and then you push your belly button and
then your butt falls off
and then you hold your butt and you have
to dig and you find a little baby
no but also you referenced me but you
you didn't say who
who got you know like immaculately
cream-filled
to make baby yoda it could have been a
treat i want to talk to that tree though
and see you know who's been like
big dick little green guy just like that
tree
[Music]
and then that tree popped out an egg and
it's the miracle of life but you know
what's weird about it
is uh it is miraculous and like whatever
happened to smee
was not done through sexual
fertilization on a cellular level it was
done through
magic right so like those midichlorians
just to the fact that they nested
in shmee's womb they could have nested
in some weird midichlorian patch
in a bog somewhere that like a little
yoda worm crawls out of and that was the
asexual process
i have a question slash theory but first
questions
about star wars canon you can reference
your books if you need to in
star wars is the word sperm canon does
it exist
i don't think so i think it's one of
those things sound like perfect if
apparent says can we say a dime a dozen
and felonies like they don't have dimes
in star wars
they might not have sperms sorry about
the mess
so they don't have sperm in star wars
you know what they have midi chlorine
that's what they are i'm telling you
that's what they're doing count off
we're like oh my god
his sperm rate is through the roof
even master yoda doesn't have this kind
of sperm count
what does that mean i'm not sure they
don't spend any time in hot tubs they
don't wear
tiny whities they got massive amounts of
midichlorians
busting all over the place busting mixer
again i'm a better
i mean if you had to draw a midichlorian
would it not wiggle
it probably would it probably would have
a tail i think what we actually solved
is
yes we're all connected by this unifying
spunk
called the force surrounds us and
penetrates us penetrates us
if the force passing through us is just
that spunk
then yeah everything's constantly having
sex at all times
well there's a refractory period yeah
but then
that's beautiful that's the time between
the original trilogy and then the
prequels yeah that's
their trilogy the movies are just
drinking a lot of fluids
yeah uh you said those was
for kids yeah stay in school kids and
get
get your dad there kick his ass it's
time to be a man or if you live
south of orlando have fun at prom all
right
we want to thank some friends who helped
us make this episode starting with our
friends at doordash
so between work and school chores family
stuff and figuring out the reproductive
processes of fictional characters
you have got plenty on your to-do list
give yourself one less thing to worry
about and let doordash take care of your
next meal
i literally this is true just use
doordash
right before we started shooting to eat
my meal and my driver was my neighbor
wow tip him yeah doordash is the app
that brings you food you're craving
right now right to your door
ordering is so easy just open the
doordash app choose what you want to eat
and your food
will be left safely outside your door
with the new contactless delivery
drop-off setting with over
300 000 partners in the u.s puerto rico
canada and australia you can choose
from your favorite national restaurants
like wendy's the cheesecake factory
my favorite chipotle ah that's what i
ordered
or you could pick one of your favorite
local restaurants just open the doordash
app select your favorite local
restaurant
and your food will be left at your door
and right now our listeners can get five
dollars off and
zero delivery fees on their first order
of fifteen dollars or more
i just used it just use this well philip
uh you missed your chance but everyone
else dollars off
five dollars and zero delivery fees yeah
yeah that's the code
well you gotta download the doordash app
right now and enter the code
big question so that again is five
dollars off sorry philip
and zero delivery fees on your first
order when you download the door dash
app in the app store enter the code big
question don't forget that's code big
question for five dollars off your first
order with doordash
i'm just gonna start entering big
question on every episode they either
have been a sponsor of us or will be you
threatening me master jedi
we also want to thank our friends at
purple mattress for sponsoring this
episode
sure most mattresses look the same with
sheets on them
and the same goes for pillows but and
people
and for people and baby yodas and
oranges well if you peel away those
sheet
clothes look at what's inside the
mattress and pillow
you will see that they aren't all
created equal so purple mattress has
created this cutting edge technology
that they call the purple grid
it is a patented comfort technology that
instantly adapts to your body's natural
shape and sleep style
then they have all these air channels
designed to neutralize body heat and to
keep you cool
i started using a pillow it's like oh
it's like sleeping on nothing and
everything at the same time
by the way i used that pillow before we
gave it to you no
it was pretty wonderful actually it was
really nice
uh what's your sleep style um
on my back until i snore too much and
then i have to roll over on my side
that's my sleep style
don't know what i say i also
started snoring in the past two years
it's just age
does baby yoda snore on next week a big
question now the same tech
in their mattresses is also in the
purple pillows they're engineered for
head and neck support and airflow and i
can attest to that
since i've got uh me and phillips purple
harmony pillow
and it is super soft and oh so nice for
my sleepy little head
it keeps me sleeping like a log and a
very cool
and comfortable log you can try every
purple product risk free with free
shipping of returns and purple has
financing available for as low as
0 apr for qualified customers so
experience the purple grid and you'll
sleep like never before go to purple.com
big question 10 and use promo code big
question 10
for a limited time you'll get 10 off any
order of 200 dollars or more
oh phillip did he miss this one too
why aren't you telling me i ordered this
pillow i'm so
sorry why aren't i not getting the hook
up on these items
well don't be like phillip get on this
ahead of time that is purple.com
big question 10 promo code big question
10 for 10
off any order of 200 or more terms apply
god dang it get that purple stuff get
that purple stuff
now we're going to move on to some
bite-sized options phillips going to
answer a question for us are you ready
phillip
okay you got this you got this you got
this all right a tripper on discord asks
how does dinjarin know how to speak
tuscan
oh yeah from the first episode of this
new season you can speak tuscany
eric remind us what tuscan sounds like
oh god eric words have meaning dude i
feel like it's uh what i did was
offensive
absolutely and i apologize okay we know
from season one
already mando already you did a little
bit of tus
tuscan speak using hand signals which by
the way i don't know if you know the new
ones they actually consulted with uh asl
expert to like kind of um develop it and
also i don't know if you know but i know
how to do
all of seasons of love in american sign
language oh do it
[Music]
but then he was so we kind of slightly
knew that he was familiar with language
but
it was only the hand signals so actually
this exists in asl
when you're using your hands to
communicate you also have this whole
other characterization of your face
where the expressions that you have on
your face
enhance or make the sign you've used a
little bit more detailed
so i'm thinking the hand signals for the
tuscan people are very straightforward
easy to to communicate ideas that are
maybe a little bit
more necessary at the beginning like a
conversation you might need to discuss
with the tuscan quickly like may we pass
here sure yeah what can we exchange uh
you up
it's just like but that's all he needed
back in season one so i don't think he
actually like very recently and suddenly
learned the vocalizations i think that's
just this added layer
that he didn't need the first time he
told gorkharesh
john leguizamo basically in his clown
makeup from spawn
that he's been spending a lot of time on
tatooine so he would have run into them
uh plenty of times and we know that
tuscans kind of like act like
everybody's
in their territory and they hate it
they're like new yorkers and barca
tourists
and so he probably has encountered them
a lot and needed to
learn more of the language and then just
in general as a bounty hunter he has no
allegiances to any specific place
so it would benefit him to learn the
languages of a bunch of different places
over the years especially just to get
like details and like solve his little
weekly mysteries that uh he goes on i
don't speak whatever language that is
you speak hatiz
and so now he also just reveals to us
that there's a deeper layer that he
knows which is the vocalizations
to do the the more complicated we have
to work together
bart bart you know i understand your
frustrations
i know we said we'd see other people you
know other
tuscans look exactly like you so
is that racist i don't know they're not
watching none of them are watching
that's what's on in their little eye
holes so i think he just knew it the
whole time but he just didn't need
to show it off like some people do
people that
do crossfit or whatever watch me
that makes sense i'll say between this
and between heli moto knowing the frog
language is like wow these yeah it's
kind of like how han knows
kashiki you know it's like i i want to
see han solo roar like a wookie just
once
yeah you know i think it's it's so funny
it's like so amy sedaris is a comedic
legend and you know that they were just
like just make some sounds or whatever
and she's like
crazy stuff and then they just now have
to like retroactively like turn that
into a language some linguist is like oh
she's so inconsistent but i guess that
will be an accident exactly
like how like we already had the wookies
say that you know like they'll have to
find a way to make it work which
which i love go ahead and just uh delete
everything all right hold on
chuck one more time and then make a
decision
i also just reminded myself that i used
to have that bid in college where i
would go to sing a song and i would
scream at the top of my lungs
phil was thrown off of so many karaoke
night stages
yeah no bits here sir
everyone at tgi friday spitting out
their donkey sauce wings
donkey sauce wings what what the [ __ ] is
donkey sauce
doggy sauce that's what uh you know it's
like
horse midichlorian it's it's a stop one
on the flavor town exits
oh you got donkey sauce oh my god
donkey's uh you know that's that stuff's
expensive you can
you can make quite the stallion with the
with the right chili dunky sauce all
right well speaking of spunk stories
now it's time for boxing scraps a spunk
story you renamed this segment
this week we did because our box of
scraps question this week
is what is the story about your birth or
your early childhood
that freaked you out when someone else
later told you about
it when you're older or you unrepressed
it yeah
what is a blocked out memory that you
dug back
up and you have to go to therapy now for
it i'll jump in first
so let's just jump into it i'm the
youngest of five
so each successive kid in my family has
some horrible story that the next older
sibling did
when our parents brought home the
younger sibling you guys are the
the model of the von trapps if the von
trapps each tried to murder the next
youngest one
yeah oh friedrich
[Music]
she's being drowned yeah like so
my i have one older brother who's seven
years older than me
and when the next oldest kid my sister
katie
was brought home as a baby my brother
who was four he wanted a little
brother so bad because he had been the
you know he had two older sisters so
this would have been three girls one boy
and he's just like i can we throw her in
the river and try to
start over and try again what is he a
spartan yeah
your brother kind of is a spartan oh
yeah he's a badass
you are very much an athenian oh no i'm
the spartan who just died on the side of
the mountain i'm like oh i'm glad
there's
youtube has a job in 2020. yeah
eric it's it was just a task you go no
leave me
i found a little noise i like it here
it's warm doordash chipotle side of
mountain but
the story for my birth talked to some
people in the family they say it's not
true others swear it was true
that my older sister katie she's three
years old when i was born and had a
little coloring desk
and legend has it that the moment news
came out
that mommy gave birth to little baby
eric
that three-year-old katie waddled over
to a while because she was a little girl
she's just a little girl and a little
girl girl i grabbed a sharp letter
opener opener
went back to her coloring desk and
stabbed it in the desk
years later uh they say that you could
see the wound in the wooden coloring
desk
where the stab it happened and it looks
like the new rockstar is lightning yeah
let's become a harry potter origin story
youtuber sorry
but uh according to half of my family
they say that would have been impossible
that
there's no way my sister could it's kind
of like when you hear the story of like
oh yeah
they they drowned 18 cats when they made
the incredible journey
and then i'm like oh yeah that makes
true that's a separate story i i
was told by katie when i was older that
homeward bound that they drowned
18 cats when they shot the cassie scene
just in rehearsals like yeah there's
just like state chants throwing in cat
after cat
they're like oh that one didn't make it
i repeated this story years later to
co-workers and they're like
what the hell are you talking about
there is a sad story about my life
notice that katie to her credit was
probably thinking of another dog a cat
movie where cats stitch around i like
that your family is like
that's impossible no child could do that
but there's no other explanation and
reminds me of donald pleasance
i shot him six times so yeah dr loomis
is in my family six
times so i personally don't believe it's
true you know
i think it's mixed in with probably
story anytime you're in a big family and
the kid who's used to being the youngest
is no longer the youngest that kid
gets pissed and i think that's just
always the story no
foreshadowing of your relationship with
katie or yeah i
i have a very uh not just between me and
katie my whole family has had
growing up horror stories we have home
movies that we made where we murdered
each other all these pieces of furniture
yeah we've all been stabbed by paris
items
like a wine screw inside of the bureau
we have an annual membership at rooms to
go they're like oh the bosses are back
so every year you have a new baby your
mom
immaculate she is i'm so i
love my mom she's such a good mom she
had to put up with so much
yes two things are coming to mind so
i'll just kind of say the first one
quickly
one i was very little i just learned how
to walk
and i guess like i really picked it up
quickly like it was like oh okay you can
you can walk uh and a
doctor was like that's impossible
because i had no spine wait a doctor was
in the room for your first steps
oh he had just given birth to me
my umbilical cord and i'm like well what
are we waiting for
this is crazy this is another episode of
a female doctor
femo doctor
there's days on e i'm here to see doctor
today anyway i've been watching a lot of
reality
okay so i just learned how to walk but i
guess like they were like oh
yesterday he took his first steps so
they weren't really too worried about it
but within like two days i could like
run whoa
and so my they hadn't like prepared for
that yet so my mom goes to like feed me
or something
and this is a story i found out later
and um she can't find me
and she looks she tears the whole house
apart and cannot find me anywhere
and then she goes uh and she realizes
the front door is open
so i've not only walked all the way to
the front door i managed to open it
i learned how to open doors like a
raptor and then i
i go out and i hopped on top of the
stove but so then she's like oh my god
he made it onto the street
and so she goes and she just can't see
find me anywhere
and so she literally just starts running
around the streets
trying to find me she gets blocks away
and then she sees a woman in the
distance
holding me like a baby like like as her
baby
and my mom runs up to her and the
woman's like can i help you
and she's like my my son you fight you
fight you found my son and the woman's
like
uh oh are you sure so like later my mom
realized like this woman was gonna
kidnap me
yeah she was acting like it was
absolutely her son she's like so
terrifying
can i help you um so i could have had
this whole other life
but um that was my original mom the
other thing it reminded me of but i
guess i've gone over my time i'll just
just say that you were reminding me that
that's not that bad because my mom
always tells me the story that's much
worse
about how when my brother was a little
baby she outran a tank
with him in her arms yeah yeah yeah
because of the nicaraguan revolution
and they were being chased by a tank so
that was a very unsettling story to
learn
this is what we have missed from big
question for these past months is philip
has
the craziest freaking stories of like
his early childhood just trying to save
him up for a slumdog millionaire
hopefully i'll you know go on a
millionaire or a different game show
that's
existing now a deal or no deal wheel of
fortune yeah
yeah wait that reminds me of some long
sad story
the different no deal models are like
your different moms from over the years
like
well that's incredible wow that's so
interesting uh that you
nearly ran and you know miami is a it's
a big town you could end up in a whole
different life yeah right i could have
been a contender
you could have been that convinced uh
phillip it's been so great having you
back it's been what a wonderful
homecoming
uh we learned a lot about each other
it's always more about fictional
characters
that uh we don't need to know that much
about and spunk in the star wars
universe
spunk it it flows through and binds us
[Laughter]
it's too sticky
uh and that is it for this episode of a
big question and a reminder again
check out newrockstarsmerch.com you can
find the shirts both phillip and i are
wearing and not only
do they look cool they're super super
comfortable and lots of great options
hoodies hats
oh uh i got this new hat in the mail
that uh for the first time a hat fits my
head
not with these these on but this hat is
freaking cool
uh masks all kinds of stuff that you're
gonna love great for holiday gifts great
for yourself definitely go check that
out at newarksaysmerch.com it also helps
this channel
which uh if if the anything else you
want to keep us alive
we'd appreciate that thank you phillip
for joining us this episode follow him
at philip molina uh you can follow me at
ea boss follow new rockstars on all
social media send us your big questions
using the hashtag bigquestion
and uh subscribe to our big question
podcast feed if you can leave us a nice
rating and review that helps people
hear this more and uh subscribe to of
course student rockstars here on youtube
hit that notification bell uh stay tuned
for more shows and
we'll have more mandalorian stuff coming
this friday on wikileaks but we'll see
you next time thanks everybody
feel the spunk believe in the spunk
thanks for having me back yeah it's good
to have you back
bye bye bye
[Music]
you